all right so welcome back everyone for
the last talk last day in the workshop
and great to have Adam we are here for
talking about the power of predictions
of online legislation Thanks
yeah I had the last talk at the bootcamp
too so I think the organizers are trying
to tell me something so this is this
talk is about predictions and I guess
the motivation here is that really in
almost any online algorithms problem or
online decision problem that you do in
real life you have some sort of forecast
or prediction that you're using and yet
when it's algorithm designers we we
don't really have a very good sense of
how to use that information to design
better algorithms so you know concretely
you know if you think about how we use
predictions you know I came up I flew in
today so I woke up today down in you
know Pasadena I had to look at the
weather at Berkeley to decide what to
wear you know then when I got here on
the play and I did figure out whether to
take Bart or uber to get here and you
know all of these tools have predictions
forecasts that you make use and then
wanted to see how what the impact of the
Tesla Sun City merger was on my
portfolio
so I think that's what I was doing in
the car and you know that I'm booking my
next fight for coming up in a few weeks
and so you look at that and all of these
you know forecasts are crucial in these
decision makings and actually
philosophically if you if you talk to a
neuroscientist these days though the
best understanding we have over the
brain is as a prediction machine so you
know there's a small little bit of it
that's used for activation but most our
brain is actually used for making
predictions and in some sense you know
that's that's what what we do in our
lives with almost every decision we make
and as you know as algorithms people as
computer scientists we a lot about
making predictions we feel like we have
lots of tools we can do this pretty well
there are a lot of talks in this
workshop and over this term about how do
you make good predictions but there have
been very few talks or papers really
thinking about how you use the
predictions and yeah and what I mean by
use is you know think about just as a
thought experiment would you do a
different algorithm for route planning
in a graph for example if you knew your
predictions were precise or if you knew
they were you know had some heavy tailed
noise or Gaussian
noise with that impact the way you
designs the algorithm at all we have a
good answer for that and same thing with
you know that's even in the case but if
you think of correlation you know if
your if your noise is iid versus short
term correlated versus long term
correlated clearly that should change
the way your algorithm uses the
prediction and we don't have a guide or
at least I don't have a guide for how to
do that right now and I think this is
something that practitioners you know
the side of me that works on really
designing algorithms for data centers
and smart coding stuff you're using
forecasts you know a lot about their
accuracy their correlation structure and
yet I have no idea how to use that to
change what I do for my control
algorithms so kind of you know I think
that's that's the vision here and I'd
say there's a lot of work on algorithm
design that uses predictions but not on
how to guide an algorithm so so if you
think of this and the reason for this is
really it's a hard problem to model so
what do we mean by using predictions in
an algorithm if you you know think about
people in this room and myself included
most of the things that we do or some
sort of worst-case view of prediction
and we saw a few of these today where
you know the prediction is in some sense
a little bit noisy in part of the
instance maybe there's a few data points
with some noise or an adversary controls
a few but then it's perfect in the rest
of the instance so there's this sense in
which you're really optimistic about the
things that you know being perfect and
real or near-perfect and really
pessimistic about the things that you
don't know being adversarial and you
know as a tool for modeling the impact
of predictions on algorithms this is
problematic because you're sort of sort
of simultaneously
you know going in two different
directions with your model and who knows
which is going to win then you know the
stochastic community I know there's a
bunch of people you know that some
models there and our results there you
take us the caustic assumption about
something that's underlying maybe make a
prediction of that process but any
result you get about algorithm design
there is going to be really fragile to
the underlying stochastic assumptions in
that model and it's it's not clear that
that's the right way to go either the
systems people you know I have my share
of systems papers where all you do is
you take an algorithm you throw in some
predictions you see if they work if they
work great but now you're just using for
count you're using old data how is this
going to extend in the real we're
it's it's just none of it is very
satisfactory when you think about
designing an algorithm that uses
predictions and how those predictions
should impact the design of the
algorithm I think you know it kind of
really ties in to the semester in this
workshop where you need something
between these you need a way of
capturing some of what you know in the
stochastic noise of the predictions
while still capturing enough of the
adversarial viewpoint that you can you
know get the model free to some extent
or robust to some extent so this talk is
basically an attempt that we've been
doing for the last year and a half or
two to try to build some models and some
analysis techniques that allow you to
look at predictions in this beyond worst
case way and we basically have been able
to get a you know first set of results
along this line of how structure of
prediction noise should impact algorithm
design in one or two particular examples
at this point and the one where we have
the richest story is online optimization
and so that's what I'll talk about today
we've also done it in some demand
response problems and we're working on
it and some scheduling problems so I can
tell you about that was offline if
you're interested but the idea is really
to say you know how should the structure
of prediction noise impact algorithm
design so we'll do this in online convex
optimization and to really make
predictions crucial it will look at a
little tweak of the standard Osio model
where you have switching costs or a
regularizer
in the in the cost function and so the
story is you know just like standard
Osio you pick a point in some convex
action space then you're presented with
a convex cost function you pay a cost
according to that function then you pick
another point your and the difference
from the standard is you pay a cost a
norm norm for the difference between
those two choices and then you incur the
cost on that you know the next convex
action places so keep going this way and
so you have your switching cost for how
far you're moving between rounds and you
have your action cost or your operation
cost from the cost function for that
round so that's the model and so here it
is you know you're choosing X
represented cost etc you have your
coffee or convex cost here and you have
some norm as a switching cost and you're
just trying to minimize cost in turn on
Langley
we'll get to predictions the idea in a
second but but really you know even in
this form you know the
something that's been used all over the
place we started looking at this because
of the domain of sustainable Dana Center
design so it turns out this is a really
nice tool for capturing if you want to
adjust the capacity of a data center
it's a match
you know the workload coming in and the
availability of renewable energy and
these sorts of things you can do after a
lot of modeling work you can fit it into
this framework and we've actually been
very successful there so you know it's
not just a you know an application that
I throw up there and hand wave away
we've released products with HP and and
these sorts of algorithms are actually
running in Apple data centers managing
the renewable resources of you know of
their portfolio we've also been you know
since then this is stuff that is with
you so mule is the leader at Caltech
we've been applying the same algorithms
to speech planning and camera planning
our speech animation and camera planning
with Disney and so here so actually I
should say where does the switching cost
come in data center so the switching
cost comes in data centers because when
you turn on or off a server you switch
it into and out of the power savings
mode the wear and tear cost of doing
that is about the same as running a
server for half an hour to an hour and
so you really have to think carefully of
whether you want to turn things off or
on
before you do it and you know that cost
is on the order of the operation cost so
you can't ignore it
and so that gives you kind of the
smoothing turn here the cost is then
associated with actual performance and
energy of having the servers on in these
two you know in-camera planning you of
course need the switching cost is
capturing the fact that you don't want
to move a camera if you're watching a
sporting event for example and just jerk
it and jerk it jerk it you want to move
it smoothly and so you need some
regularizer to ensure smooth movement
and the same thing in speech animation
and so I can tell you more about those
offline but the work on camera planning
was in Sports Illustrated this summer
and the animation stuff is being
productized by Disney right now for some
of their upcoming movies and so it's a
real practical model where you can make
impact with algorithms and and all three
of those cases that we've been working
on predictions are really crucial to the
way you use them in practice you don't
use it in a absence of information about
the future you have a lot of information
that is accurate but not precise
about the future and you need to figure
out how to use it and you want to use it
differently depending on the structure
of then placing these algorithms and so
you know just to be you give us some
context before we move to predictions if
you think about the way people analyze
these there's it's sort of silly to call
it to communities but really there's two
metrics that people work on when they
study these problems regret or
competitive ratio and and basically I
don't need to put this up for this but I
want to put up just to highlight that
the difference between them
you know regret this additive
competitive ratio is multiplicative but
the key difference is you know regret
you're comparing to a best static choice
and a competitive ratio you're comparing
to the true offline optimal which is
which may be dynamic in this setting and
in in the data center case as an example
really what you want is both of these so
in the data center case comparing to
regret is like saying currently you're
running a static set of servers if
you're gonna switch to a dynamic policy
you want it to do better than what
you're getting with the static set of
servers so you want no regret but if
you're gonna switch you don't want to
have to switch again a year later so you
want to be near optimal to make the
switch and so when we were interacting
with HP and and the other companies
around these things in some sense the
big argument for them was that we could
do well for both of these and if we were
only doing well for one of them they
wouldn't have been willing to take up
the algorithms and so it was really
something where you wanted an algorithm
for both of these measures and you know
if you look at the literature there are
very few papers maybe some from avram
side that that are really looking at
both and so for regret you want to be
subletting regret for constant for a
competitor a shoe you want to be a
constant and you know the much less
studied problem is is can you do both
yeah so I think everybody in here and
probably knows a lot of these so I kind
of good are gonna go over this really
quickly but if you if you're not
familiar with this literature please
speak up and ask a question you know if
you think of algorithms for Oh Co that
too well for regret almost anything
works well gradient descent Newton's
method I mean it's pretty easy to be no
regret and most of those initial
algorithms are proven in the case where
you don't have switching costs adding a
switching cost doesn't change anything
you add a switching cost you get
basically the same bounds and it just
magically turns out that the cost from
the switching cost balances precisely
with the cost from the actual online or
the actual convex function and so things
just work out really nicely so you know
there you can do really well you can be
you know order to a routine regret and
with pretty simple algorithms
competitive ratio is not as satisfying
so to do well for competitive ratio here
basically it's only possible to do that
in low dimensions so there's a three
competitive algorithm that's
deterministic for one dimension to
competitive randomized in two dimensions
already there's not really a clean
identification of the constant but you
can be constant competitive beyond that
there's no constant competitive
algorithms that I know of the the
two-dimensional Lizano plan the one so
basically you know you can only do well
in low dimensional cases and for high
dimension and we know that it's you
can't have a constant competitive
in-between it's not completely clear and
so this is pretty good this is okay you
you'd hope that at least for slow
dimensions you could do well here and
maybe the surprising thing this is this
is a result that we had just a few years
ago is that you can't do well for both
even in a one-dimensional case and so
it's really you know without predictions
without some knowledge about the future
you're kind of stuck if you want to try
to be good compared to the static
solution and within a constant factor of
the optimal solution and this is it's a
little bit weird so it's useful to get
some intuition for why this is true and
basically the reason why is in some
sense if you want to do well for regret
you have
to be very much like gradient descent so
what do I mean by that well you can
prove you know that you can't do well
for both which is this is the formal
statement with just instances that mix
between two linear cost functions you
have a you know one that slipped one way
one that's looked the other way and what
what happens if you do a gradient
descent like algorithm here you
basically get stuck on the upper
envelope of this because wherever you
are the adversary can give you that side
you're going to make a small step in the
gradient direction when you cross over
you're gonna stay on the upper envelope
and then you're gonna settle back down
and you're gonna end up around there
okay and so that's great because you're
matching the static optimal but now I
just choose these slopes and I can make
that very far away from the dynamic
optimal and so no algorithm that's kind
of learning that point can be good for
competitive ratio and on the other hand
if you're going to do well for
competitive ratio you can show that you
have to be kind of sticky and make big
jumps and so to do well for competitive
ratio you basically stick at one point
you you play it it's good for a little
while eventually the adversary makes it
bad but you stick with it for enough
time that it's you're sure it's worth it
to switch and then you have to switch
all the way over to the other side you
don't you know you there's no messing
around you just take the big jump to the
good side yeah and you'll do the same
thing you'll stick there well it's good
for a while eventually the adversity
I'll give you a bad class but you'll
stick with it until you're sure that
it's worth it to switch and you can
think of this ski rental problem you
stick with it and tell your cost is at
least is what much is what it would be
to swap over to the other side and then
you come back and so this is great for
staying within a constant factor of the
optimal because dependent if you're if
you're not if you're just the right
level of stickiness you're staying close
to this but if I make the static optimal
really close to the dynamic optimal
you're giving up more than a you know
additive factor compared to the dynamic
or compared to the static optimal and so
you can basically show that this is you
know that little hand wavy thing is
completely formal you have to do well
for competitive ratio you have to be
sticky like that to do well for regret
you have to be kind of learning the
upper envelope and so there's no way an
algorithm can do both
so it's kind of disappointing and but it
really kind of motivates too you know in
some sense lower bounds that you'd hope
you could get around using information
about the future by using some sort of
beyond worst-case analysis and that's
kind of what what I'll tell you today is
that in some sense what you hope is you
know I I can do well for higher
dimensions for competitive ratio if I
use predictions and I could do well for
them jointly to if I use predictions
basically the answer to both of those
will be yes you can do well for them
jointly and this again
and using pretty simple algorithms but
we'll take a little while to get there
any questions about that part
okay so before we can get to there I
have to say I think of you model for
predictions so so far I've just it's
been the classic online version of both
of these problems so the way I'm going
to incorporate predictions into these is
to basically view these as tracking
problems so you can think of this as
like a lasso type problem in an online
lesson where we have some you know
parameter Y of T that is maybe the
optimal configuration of your data
center and you're trying to stay as
close to that as possible
you have predictions of the solar you
have predictions of the workloads and
this lets you sort of have a forecast of
what the optimal configuration will be
and you're wanting to stay as close to
that as possible now your forecasts are
time dependent and evolving over time so
imagine you know that maybe you know the
current one but at time T you have a
prediction of Y of T plus one and a
prediction of Y of T plus two and so on
and these are possibly noisy we'll talk
about how we model the noise and what
those look like over the next few slides
but just right now think of them in
general and you know the idea is thing
to do what and so so you think of you
know at time one you're making a
decision with some noisy and for me our
time zero you're making a decision x1
with some noise the information about
the future then you get a realization
you know but you have new updated
predictions about the future because one
time step point by you learned a little
bit more so your predictions were
refined and then you go forward in that
way so that's kind of the information
flow lasso is a good example to think of
for what this parameterised cost
function might be but you know we don't
care what that is for our results it's
just kind of I'll get to that in a
second so so right now I haven't told
you anything about what these
predictions actually look like and I
think that's the the rub in all of this
is what is a good way of modeling the
evolution of predictions that still lets
us do analysis and this is where we get
between kind of stochastic and
worst-case in the viewpoint today so but
before we get to that it'll just do the
model that probably everybody here is
most familiar with first so that we can
see how it works and what's kind of
pretty unsatisfying about it so then
this is where we started you know the
the TCS you know vanilla view would be
okay
have predictions at any given point I'll
say I can look ahead perfectly for some
prediction window size W steps you know
if I want to be a little bit fancy maybe
I'll say I can look ahead and there
gonna be some distribution air but the
air is gonna be bounded by epsilon
within that window and then beyond that
it's adversarial right this is there's
tons of papers like this in lots of
domains and it's kind of it's the
natural thing to do right but let's see
what the consequence is here so on the
algorithmic side it's given this model
and given a predictions in these online
problems if you have any connection with
control theory there's a immediate thing
that you think to do which is model
predictive control or receding her
Meissen control this is the generation
Erik answer for all problems like this
is some variation of recited receding
horizon control and what we mean by that
is you look at the information you have
you have W steps of prediction so we're
gonna use those W steps of prediction we
know they're perfect so given that
they're perfect let's just solve the
problem optimally given that information
that gives us you know the trajectory XT
plus 1 through X T plus w the first one
of those we're going to implement we're
going to use and then we're going to
move on and then we'll get you know our
update since there since this is perfect
actually I didn't even need to be this
general about the way I wrote this
because these ones are exactly the same
you just get one new piece of
information and that's now the perfect
prediction of time W plus one you use
that you do your predictions along ok so
what do we get so with this model you
get something that's OK in one dimension
you get what you hope for which is your
as your prediction window gets larger
and larger you get closer and closer to
the optimal and the Takei's kind of as
well as you could hope you can show that
no algorithms going to be able to do
better than this and you know that's
that's kind of you get sort of a 1 plus
1 over W your predictions where the
window is long enough your quote you're
basically optimal a problem is outside
of one dimension you don't get this
behavior anymore in fact your lower
bounded by a constant and you just
beyond the point don't get any better as
you get more information even though the
extra information you're getting is
perfect this is a little weird and so it
doesn't improve as she goes and and this
is I have too much to say otherwise I
would stop here and show you an example
why but it's it's a little bit
counterintuitive it as to why this might
happen but basically the idea is you're
not sticky enough you're you're you can
be convinced to move you know X 1 a lot
every time step because you're not
paying attention to why you got where
you are you're not looking past at all
so you don't remember that you just took
a big move to get where you are and
you're very willing to take another big
move right away and the adversary can
take advantage of that so you need to
fix something the the fix or one one way
to fix this is something that you know
it's week of receiving horizon control
that we call averaging fixed horizon
control and this now I'll tell you what
it is in a second but it looks you get 1
plus 1 over W for any dimension you know
so it's it's exactly you know what the
best you could hope for in this up to
constants so what it does is it
basically combines a bunch of worse
algorithms there are a bunch of really
stupid algorithms so it combines a bunch
of fixed horizon control algorithms
which what they do is they look at the
information you have you know T plus 1
of T plus W and instead of you know this
is exactly what receiving horizon
control would do but receding horizon
control would only implement the first
one and then move forward and you know
use new information to compute the next
step fixed arising control says ok I'll
just do all of those I'll wash my hands
of it I won't pay attention to any new
information until that whole window has
passed and then I'll start to look at
the predictions again and I'll do the
next step and I'll just bend things that
way so so what a virgin fixture izing
controller does is it takes W of those
algorithms and
averages the choices nothing so it's
kind of a smooth or a regular eyes
version of weaker algorithms and the
intuition for it connects with what I
was saying this in a sense you pay
attention to why you got where you are
because you're paying attention to an
algorithm that made this choice so
you're averaging why you got where you
are with the ones that are purely
looking at so you're having some that
are purely looking ahead and
that are clearly looking backwards and
so the average kind of balances that and
and the average is really important here
if you if you don't do a uniform average
this doesn't work it has to be a uniform
average or uniform mixture of these if
you prefer to think randomized yeah so
you could imagine you know two ways to
implement one of us averaging the other
is just I have W of them I'll pick one
of them that will be my action and I do
that uniformly at random W scale with
the horizon the full horizon for the
problem so if they're completely
independent right now so the full
horizon is capital T whatever W pick
that's the boundary good oh yeah in the
in the in the bad result and the bad
result it doesn't scare with that but
there's a tie between the dimension and
W that you need to get the adversarial
result to work out the capital T doesn't
matter in any of these yeah then you're
fine yeah okay so there's a but here so
this this is you know great in terms of
you improve with prediction window but
still you can't this doesn't do well for
both competitive ratio and regret and in
fact you can show that no in this model
of perfect predictions with adverse AO
after your W there's no online algorithm
that can do well for competitive ratio
and you regret again and this is
basically you can just take the same
example that I showed you before and
extend it up it's not such a hard proof
to show this so really you need you need
more than constant look ahead to be able
to do well for both here and and this
just isn't satisfying actually both of
these results aren't very satisfying
because you know you're you're needing
unbounded prediction windows to do well
in both right so if you're gonna be near
optimal here you need to look really far
ahead and if you're gonna be uh you know
constant competitive and no regret
you're going to look really far ahead
and if we think about reality the
further I look ahead the more noisy this
information is the less likely it's
actually going to be useful so if doing
well really depends on looking two years
ahead with my forecast
I'm not going to do well in a real
situation because those two year I had
forecasts are going to be basically
useless so there's just you know I've
you these results is basically showing
what's wrong with the model of perfect
to look ahead rather than as useful
results in themselves and I think you
know it then it makes you go back it
really shows that you know the you're
both too optimistic and too pessimistic
and this result but the pessimism is
kind of you know the optimism lets you
get the positive result but the
pessimism is still so much that you
can't get over the regret versus
competitive ratio lower vent
those are both cost problems so what do
you do if you want to improve this
what's the next model that you could
think about well you could say let me
say iid noise for each of these prick
shion's you know that's not so great
you're not getting refined well maybe
you could make it and also you're not
getting worse as you look ahead maybe
you could make it depend on how far
you're looking ahead but then how do you
find it it's it's kind of and also
correlation structure is really the key
thing if it's sunny at noon tomorrow
it's likely sunny at 12:01 tomorrow so
if I'm forecasting solar you know that's
gonna be important if I think it's gonna
be sunny and it's actually cloudy at
noon it's probably still cloudy at 12:01
that correlation structure is gonna
dominate my air actually it's not it's
not something that you can ignore so you
you this is sort of not really a natural
way to go in for practical situations
maybe you can do something stochastic
but then you're so specific to the model
if you think about the data center
example where you're trying to you know
you go integrate renewable energy into a
data center you would need to have a
stochastic model for the workloads a
stochastic model for the solar a
stochastic model for the temperature
outside so you can understand its impact
on cooling you need to put all these
together you need to make assumptions in
all of these places and you know then
all of a sudden your result will be
really fragile to all those assumptions
that's not a natural way to go either
yeah so so what do you do so what I'm
going to show you is our best attempt so
far it's far from perfect but I think
it's already a big step towards having
something that is much more general
while also being practical and tractable
in in terms of looking at these and I
can sort of summarize
the idea of it is you take a noisy
prediction model from the filtering
community and you use that in the
context of an adversarial analysis so
that's the high level
I know explain what that means here and
so basically the prediction noise is
going to satisfy this so the whole model
for the prediction noise is on the
screen right now the way to think of it
is you know the real value think of
maybe it's easier to write this with a -
so this - this is your prediction noise
right so your prediction noise is
captured by this where you have your per
step noise which is iid so this is kind
of if you look one step ahead
how much uncertainty is there and that's
reasonable to be eye adizero I mean all
that sort of stuff but then you weight
it by some sort of an impulse function
which captures the correlation structure
and this looks familiar to anybody who's
took in a class in around signal
processing and filtering but we're using
it in a very different way than they do
and so so what does this give you if you
kind of unroll it a little bit you see
that basically if you move one step
forward your predictions are refined in
a very natural way because you've
learned one of these events you've
learned the realization of one of these
so you have a nice kind of filtration of
how these predictions evolve and you
know because of this you know additive
noise thing as you look further ahead of
course there's extra noise there's more
of these that you don't know so you're
vance goes up exactly the way you think
you'd want it to you can get basically
any correlation structure you want by
putting in FS of different forms so
shortly and wrong range ia just be one
in all zeros you know all of these sorts
of things are just special cases of this
and you know even better if you're
really writing the optimal predictor for
a wide sense stationary process that's
the Wiener filter the noise looks like
this if you're writing a you know way to
move an average filter for a random walk
the noise the basis properties
same thing with common filters and
linear dynamical systems this is this is
the noise this is the real noise
structure and more generally you can
prove that you know kind of
axiomatically any any linear predictor
in a stationary environment is going to
have a noise that satisfies this form
what really captures what you'd expect
if you were using a predictor in a
context where it was designed for but
the important thing is I haven't said
anything about the underlying process I
can tell you what the noise process
looks like without saying anything about
the instance and so we can use this
noise process and now study still an
adversarial instance for the problem so
the idea is you know it's really beyond
worst case in the sense that you know
you're still but you can think of it as
either specifying the initial
predictions or specifying the the Y of T
itself the adversary is giving you that
and now it's kind of a you know there's
a noisy app there's a noisy Oracle that
the adversary has to give you too so the
adversary specifies the instance to make
you bad but along with it they have to
give you a noisy Oracle and this
constrains what that noisy Oracle can do
that's the model and you know it's only
useful in the sense that it it's pretty
general and we can actually do analysis
now for Osio subject to this likes so
how well can an algorithm do here's
here's the result for fhc so this is
that averaging of the dumb fixed horizon
control algorithms if you have a verging
fixture eyes in control you can have a
constant competitive ratio and
sub-linear regret with a constant size
prediction window and you can actually
the the key thing here is you can
actually figure out what the optimal
length to look ahead is because you know
depending on the correlation structure
and the noise structure and how bad
things get you don't want to look too
far ahead you actually want to optimize
what information you're using in your
algorithm and so there is such an
optimal that optimal is always a
constant look ahead of length and you
can define it in a very computationally
tractable way and then there's there's
sort of one caveat which is under this
prediction model you can't always do
well and so these conditions are
basically capturing when it's when it's
possible to have a constant competitive
ratio for any algorithm or something
your gut for any algorithm and so if
it's possible for an algorithm to do it
ahe does it I know times both
simultaneously
which Sta oh sorry static so that's
that's static yeah and so this if
there's static cost is at least that the
optimal cost us at least that yeah and
then I wrote it an expectation but
there's concentrations results that you
can prove here too and so that's kind of
the first cut and it this kind of gets
at one of the points which is like we
can now sort of use a result like this
at least for a HC to say how you should
design the algorithm differently how far
should the algorithm look ahead
depending on whether the prediction
errors are noisy or not correlated or
not all these sorts of things but it
doesn't really think much about how you
design the algorithm yet because this is
just one particular algorithm you know
do you always want to use a fhc or are
there some correlation structures where
you would want to use receiving horizon
control or some other algorithm like
that you know we don't have that yet so
can you do better and you can and
actually for some class we you know we
have a first result that shows how you
can tune in however them depending on
the correlation structure of the
predictions and that you really do want
to do very different things depending on
the correlation structure yeah
no distributional assumptions other than
unbiased and the ER ID but sorry white I
thought you were hinting at Gaussian no
so there they are iid but they're
arbitrary distribution okay so to get at
this idea of how you tune an algorithm
for for the prediction noise structure
we'll look at a particular class of
algorithms and we made this up this is
in a common class but but it's a pretty
general one in the context of receding
horizon control like algorithms and so I
call these committed horizon control
mechanisms and it's kind of the natural
generalization of the two algorithms
I've shown you so far where you do
exactly the same thing you know with
your fixer eyes and control algorithm
ahc would have done the whole trajectory
here NPC would have done one and I kind
of view this as committing to these so
so fixed horizon control commits
all of them and doesn't change its mind
even if new information comes in and so
we're gonna commit to some number of
them B and B is kind of between one in
the prediction window lengths and you
get you know NPC or sorry receiving
right control if you do B equals one and
you get a fifty see if you to V equals W
and you can imagine wanting to do
something in between or maybe or maybe
not depending on the noise structure and
and that's what we can get at and so
you're doing all these and then again
you're averaging and like I said before
the in this kind of algorithm you you
basically always want to average there's
nothing really to improve by doing some
other weighted average here you really
don't want to do a uniform average and
for any given algorithm it's it's pretty
easy to or not easy but you can get
results for how to optimize W and so the
key design choice that's really not
understood about these algorithms is
this commitment level what's the impact
of that so you know just to get you to
try to anticipate the results a little
bit you can think for yourself now if
maybe the easiest case is iid so suppose
prediction noise is completely iid so
that impulse function that f is just one
and then all zeros what you want to do
receding horizon control what you want
to do ahc would you want to have
something in between wasn't obvious to
me at all
what you would want to do for even the
IAD case whether you would want to do
something in-between or not but we can
give some results that provide in
tonight and so this this I've simplified
the form here so you don't see the
prediction window in this you just see
the V's that keeps it cleaner to
understand the talk but this is this is
what we can do to help us get at this so
this is we now made an assumption on the
on the cost function so alpha holder and
we're assuming that the f is bounded
which we didn't need either of those for
the previous result but here to make it
clean you do and and we tend to look at
competitive difference in our analyses
because then you can get from a kind of
there's a quick route to either
competitive ratio or regret depending on
and where you want to go so it's it's
nice to found this first and so
basically what you get here I guess
parameter wise that's the bound for the
D the G and alpha from the definition of
alpha holder but the write the structure
of this result is basically that you get
a turn from that is captured what you
pay due to switching costs
term that's captured from what you pay
due to prediction air and the prediction
error term this the summation over here
the the FK is the prediction error that
you incur in the first case that's the
case that prediction err that's okay so
it's a pretty simple form actually and
you know in trying to interpret it if we
come back to these questions basically
it's those questions are asking what's
the impact of these fees and you can see
that the impact of commitment on proton
switching costs is pretty clear the more
commitment you have the better things
get and this is the intuition I tried to
give you about a fhc where it's it's
forcing you to be more sticky you pay
attention to the past and so you're not
willing you're not it's not as easy to
fool you into switching as it is for an
algorithm like our agency but over here
you start to see that the correlation
structure is really going to matter
because the correlation structure is
going to impact your case that
prediction error and how that average is
over K and so depending on how this
interacts with this you're gonna get a
very different you know either an
intermediate for you a small V or a
large V is your optimal thing just to
sort of work through this if you take
the case of iid noise we have one in all
zeros this is nice and easy
this part goes away you get this and you
see that this term becomes a constant
and so you know these should be very
large so a fhc is best so it's very easy
to work out what it is in that case the
other cases are more complicated but you
can start to look at them too so here's
kind of the efficiency bound as a
function of V so efficiency bound V this
is the ID case you know this V is large
is better if you go to something that's
long-range correlated you get completely
the opposite behavior so you want to do
something like RHC and you know really
move quickly if the if the prediction
error is long-range correlated in most
cases short lage correlated it's a
little bit you know it's nice its
nine-month high tonic it's a little
interesting in shape and you can think
of other interesting cases if the
correlation error is exponentially
decaying you get again something that
has this you know but convex shape and
you can start to work these out from the
theorem it's I'm making it a little
simpler so you shouldn't you shouldn't
interpret that all short-range dependent
look like this all along range depending
look like this and so on it's actually
really a delicate and it depends on the
the switching costs and in the
prediction term so there's threshold
inquiry to one of these cases but that
really highlights even more why you need
results like this one because you know
it's as far as we can tell there's not a
real general answer there's there's
there's resh holds but if you want to
try to figure out for a particular
course and structure it really depends
on how how impactful the switching costs
are and you can have really very
different behaviors depending on the
structure how the prediction error
impacts the design of the algorithm yeah
so that graph was just graphing your
bounds yeah oh you're bounced tight
enough I can sort of take that at face
value there yeah so they're they're very
tight so I think you know this I view is
the the kind of main result of talk in
the sense that it really as far as I
know it's kind of a first case at least
in the results I'm aware of where you
can say structural properties of
prediction noise change the design of
the algorithm and clearly it's limited
right this is one particular class of
algorithms I have no claim that these
are the best algorithms for this problem
there's going to be other ways that you
can do this but this is at least within
the class of model predictive control
algorithms kind of a capturing or how
you design them as a function of the
British there I think there's lots of
open questions taking this theme more
generally so so in fact so kind of the
goal of a talk isn't so much for you to
you know walk out and result I'm hoping
instead you walk out and you say okay
predictions in the context of online
algorithms this is important you know in
this one talk we did it for a particular
class of algorithms in a particular
problem and we can kind of understand
how you optimize W to capture the
accuracy and how you optimize V to
capture the correlation structure but
how does this impact other problems
route planning problems you know
problems in very different case of
shapes is chasing subspace problems you
can think of lots of contexts where
basically any online problem add
predictions about the future you know
pieces of the instance how does that
change the design of the algorithm it's
a very important problem for practice
and hopefully we can make some progress
in developing a theory
every day discounting would help you in
some cases where longer inspections or
discounted day by some geometric factor
or something like that in some sense
instead of having this fixed w have a
discount I doubt it will make much of a
difference honestly yeah I
we didn't investigate it that much
because you can already do pretty well
with the hard threshold and and that's
kind of the way most of these algorithms
look it it's a little hard to set you
know if you just start discounting too
much than you know if you if you take a
geometric discount and you're just going
to basically be ignoring those anyway so
you might as well threshold at some
point that's kind of our intuition but
but it would be interesting to look at
see if that intuition is right what
happens if you are thinking in terms of
no maximization but we like the data
center case you have some revenue you
know whatever these costs yeah the same
stuff is fine so that in I can talk to
you about the data centers offline but
you know the nothing changes in this
story if you look at kind of classic
online algorithms work like a server
problems we're kind of people thought
little about predictions then kind of
gave up is that you could sort of have
an adversary sort of slow of the world
down so you get the requests that you
get like you know a bunch requests all
the same point giving you know
information costing you zero costs the
other guy zero it's like nothing and
then you're gonna press here get a bunch
of times guys slow the world down your
predictions again one way you get around
this sort of thing is that you say if
overall cost is low that's actually
that's okay yeah and that's why looking
at the competitive difference makes
makes that kind of go away and that's
true it the other way is the correlation
structure gives a lot of information
that you don't have when you look at
these adversarial models like what
people were doing in the case server
problems